en este vídeo vamos a hablar del sentido
auditivo también llamado sentido de la
audición para que podamos escuchar algo
tienen que suceder varias cosas primero
debe existir un estímulo y en el caso
del sonido el estímulo es una onda
sonora es decir una onda sonora
presurizada esto es lo primero que se
necesita para que podamos escuchar algo
la segunda cosa que necesitamos además
del estímulo es tener un tipo de
receptor al que llegue el estímulo y en
el caso de la audición ese receptor se
conoce como célula vellosa y esta célula
vellosa es un receptor especializado que
se encuentra en la cóclea esto lo
veremos con mayor detalle más adelante
veamos estos dos elementos a qué nos
referimos con onda sonora presurizada
veamos un ejemplo cada vez que
aplaudimos con las manos escuchamos un
sonido que es bastante particular
imaginemos que estas dos líneas son dos
manos y cuando aplaudimos estas dos
líneas se juntan o sea que las manos se
juntan muy rápidamente entre las manos
hay muchas pequeñas moléculas de aire
estoy dibujando aquí como pequeños
puntos que están flotando sin molestar a
nadie y de pronto las manos se juntan y
el espacio que ocupaban estas moléculas
de aire se hace mucho más pequeño un
momento después las manos están más
cercanas entre sí
aquí las dibujo casi tocándose y lo que
pasa es que las moléculas de aire que
estaban flotando por aquí en todo este
espacio de pronto están comprimidas y
muy cercanas entre sí pueden imaginar
que cuando las manos se acercan todavía
más las moléculas de aire se compactan
aún más así que básicamente lo que
ocurre es que las moléculas de aire se
presuriza al acercarse a las manos entre
sí comprimen estas moléculas de aire y
estas moléculas de aire comprimido van a
tratar de escapar y van a hacerlo de
esta forma básicamente por donde puedan
y mientras estas moléculas de aire
escapan crean estas áreas de alta y baja
presión que es lo que trato de
representar con estas líneas estas áreas
de alta y baja presión son lo que
conocemos como ondas sonoras podemos
tener diferentes ondas sonoras
algunas ondas sonoras están muy cercanas
entre sí y otras están muy separadas
entre sí si lo dibujamos lucirá algo
como esto aquí estoy señalando un área
de alta presión y por acá hay un área de
baja presión de manera que hay áreas de
alta y baja presión y qué tan cercanos
están estos picos es lo que determina la
frecuencia así aplaudimos rápidamente o
si hay algo que produzca un sonido más
agudo un sonido de frecuencia más alta
las ondas sonoras estarán más cerca unas
de otras y lucirán más o menos así
dependiendo de la frecuencia de las
ondas percibiremos un sonido distinto
imaginemos que esta onda de acá es f1 y
esta onda de aquí es f 2 las ondas
sonoras de baja frecuencia viajan más
lejos esto sucede en el oído los sonidos
de baja frecuencia llegan más lejos y
penetran más profundamente en la cóclea
que es una estructura de la cual
hablaremos en un momento estas dos
diferentes ondas de sonido tienen
frecuencias distintas imaginemos que la
onda f1 es producida al aplaudir
en la onda f 2 es producida por alguien
hablando podemos escuchar al mismo
tiempo un aplauso y a una persona
hablando si sumáramos ambas frecuencias
la onda resultante luciría más o menos
así no es muy uniforme y se ve medio
rara si sumáramos las ondas f1 y f2
resultaría esta onda extraña que
llamaremos f3 ahora el oído tiene una
tarea bastante difícil ya que tiene que
separar esta onda extraña f3 en las dos
ondas más sencillas que la formaron f1 y
f2 y el oído puede hacer esto el oído
puede hacer esto porque las ondas
sonoras recorren distancias diferentes
dentro de la cóclea y ya que hablamos
sobre lo que es una onda sonora
presurizada ahora veamos la célula
vellosa y veamos en general la anatomía
del oído aquí tenemos un diagrama del
oído y como mencioné antes hay unas
sonoras que van a entrar al oído
imaginen que aplaudí con las manos y las
ondas de sonido van a viajar a través
del aire hacia la cabeza y la primera
parte a la que llegan es esta parte
externa
que se llama pabellón auricular es la
parte de los oídos de las personas que
podemos ver las ondas sonoras son
guiadas por el pabellón auricular hacia
esta estructura más pequeña llamada
conducto auditivo externo o meato
auditivo externo las ondas sonoras
viajan por el meato auditivo externo y
la siguiente estructura a la que llegan
es al tímpano o membrana timpánica y lo
que hace esta membrana es comenzar a
vibrar de un lado a otro conforme se
acerca la onda sonora y esto hace que se
muevan estos pequeños huesos que son
tres estos 3 huesos comienzan a vibrar
el primer hueso se llama martillo el
segundo se llama yunque y el tercer
hueso se llama estribo vamos a resumir
lo que acabamos de ver las ondas sonoras
llegan al pabellón auricular y son
guiadas hacia el meato auditivo externo
luego llegan a la membrana timpánica y
las ondas sonoras la hacen vibrar y esta
vibración hace que estos tres pequeños
huesos el martillo el yunque y el
estribo comiencen a vibrar a su vez
siguiente que ocurre es que esta ventana
oval que está pegada al estribo también
va a vibrar de un lado a otro después
encontramos fluido
esta estructura redonda pegada a la
ventana oval se llama cóclea y está
llena de fluido el movimiento de
vibración de la ventana oval ocasionado
por el estribo empuja el fluido que se
encuentra dentro de la cóclea el fluido
es empujado de esta forma y hace que
recorra toda la cóclea hasta llegar al
extremo de esta y cuando llega al
extremo de la cóclea que hace pues lo
único que puede hacer es regresar así
que el fluido se regresa el fluido
regresa por donde había venido pero no
regresa a la ventana oval sino a la
ventana redonda que estoy señalando aquí
este fluido empuja la ventana redonda el
fluido se sigue moviendo de un sentido
al otro llegando primero al extremo de
la cóclea y luego todo el camino de
regreso hasta la ventana redonda una y
otra vez hasta que la energía de la onda
sonora que hace que este fluido se mueva
finalmente se disipa
mientras tanto las células vellosas
dentro de la cóclea se mueven de un lado
a otro lo que transmite un impulso
eléctrico por el nervio auditivo que
llega al cerebro la razón por la que el
fluido no regresa a la ventana oval
después de llegar al extremo de la
cóclea y de regreso es porque en medio
de la cóclea hay una membrana voy a usar
un color diferente y esta membrana que
va por el medio de toda la cóclea se
llama órgano de corte este órgano de
corti está formado por dos elementos uno
es la membrana bacilar y el otro es la
membrana vestibular y una última cosa
que quiero mencionar es una
clasificación general de las diferentes
partes del oído esta parte que va desde
el pabellón auricular hasta la membrana
timpánica se llama oído externo después
desde el martillo hasta el estribo estos
tres huesos forman el oído medio el oído
medio va de aquí a acá mientras que el
oído externo va desde aquí
hasta acá y la tercera sección que
incluye la cóclea y algo conocido como
conducto semicircular del que no
hablamos se conoce como oído interno
estas son las tres clasificaciones
generales de las diferentes estructuras
del oído en futuros vídeos veremos con
más detalle a la cóclea y cómo el fluido
interno de esta hace que las células
vellosas disparen un impulso nervioso
hacia el cerebro en donde será
interpretado como sonido